michael mccann Sports Illustrated legal
analyst joining us on the program does
Ezekiel Elliott have options here Mike
he does Dan he can appeal back to the
commissioner and he can hope for a
reduction in the suspension if that
doesn't pan out he could go to court but
the reality is that the odds would be
stacked against him pretty decisively
particularly given the Tom Brady case
given Adrian Peterson's case the track
record for going to court is not very
good because the player conduct policy
is worded so favorably in favor of the
Commissioner does the Commissioner play
a role in this appeal in this hearing he
does it's up to him he can be the
hearing officer he can designate someone
else for that task he can also involve
other people and I imagine he will but
under the player conduct policy it's
really up to him he is the default
designate for hearing the appeal and
then it's up to him if he wants to
allocate that to somebody else where
this will be heard his keys well can he
file Kisuke oh Elliot try to have this
heard in Texas as opposed to New York
City he can try Dan but the reality is
out it would be very hard because one if
he files today it would likely be
dismissed because it's not yet ripe in
that he has to exhaust his appeal in the
NFL before a court will hear his case
alternatively if he has the hearing and
Roger Goodell decide you know what I'm
going to sustain the suspension like I
did with Tom Brady obviously the NFL
knows when Roger Goodell is going to
make that decision
they will then rush to a federal court
in New York just like the NFL did with
Tom Brady before the player in this case
Elliot can file in another court the
other quick thing
with Texas the case law there isn't
particularly favorable for somebody
challenging arbitration award which is
what this would be because Goodell in
this capacity is not the commissioner
he's an arbitrator is the NFL's
disciplinary process fair I don't think
it's fair in a general sense I think it
would be much better if there was an
independent person reviewing punishments
like in the NBA if there's a suspension
in excess of 12 games somebody can
challenge Commissioner silver and have a
neutral person hear it that said Dan the
reality is that the Union
agree to this and this is fundamentally
the problem for players is that they
assent it to something that they're now
complaining about we've seen reductions
with this but there seems to be this get
tougher policy with the NFL
whether it's overt or covert how much
does that play into the possibility of
having this reduced in what role does
Ezekiel Elliot's demeanor act of
contrition play in something like that
so then I think if Elliot goes in there
and is contrite without admitting to
committing a crime so he has to be
careful with his language if he says
look I didn't commit a crime but I
clearly haven't behaved well I was
immature I'm going to get better I
realize that I'm damaging the NFL's
brand that's really what Roger Goodell
wants to hear is because Goodell is
concerned about the impact of his
behavior or alleged behavior on the
NFL's brand if he takes that approach I
could see it reduced maybe to four games
but if instead he goes in and says I did
nothing you're wrong the evidence is
wrong I was never charged why are you
why do you know more than the police if
he takes that approach I think Goodell
will sustain six games but I'm looking
at the statement here and help me this
is a legal analyst where Elliot says I
recognize the distraction and disruption
that all of this has caused my family
friends teammates the Dallas Cowboys
organization as well as my fans for that
I am sincerely sorry then he goes on to
say I admit that I'm far from perfect
but I plan to continue to work very hard
on and off the field to mature and earn
the great opportunity that I have been
given he doesn't admit anything but he's
sort of saying hey look I'm not perfect
I apologize for everything I've done
what do you read into that or am I
reading too much into that well I
noticed he used the word it rather than
something plural so he's referring I
think from that choice of word to the
fact that he's been suspended so he's
apologizing for causing a controversy
because he's in trouble with the NFL
that's very different from saying I
apologize for my conduct in the past
over several instances where I could
have been a better man I think that
would have shown more attrition so I
don't know if he's apologizing for what
he did or instead for the controversy
that he's now facing and he did say I'm
far
from perfect although you know every one
of us would have to say that I don't
know if that's admitting all that much
Thank You Michael we appreciate it thank
staff that's Michael McCann Sports
Illustrated legal analyst in fairness to
zq ali at the full statement he says
that he strongly disagrees with the
league's finding the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience